hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
part two sigma strong
how stronger harmonization builds better
assays simplifies quality control and
strengthens results
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker stan
westgard is the director of client
services and technology for westgard
quality control
mr westgard earned his master's degree
in computer science from pace university
new york
for nearly 25 years sten has managed the
westgard website
course portal and blog creating and
administering online training as well as
editing and writing hundreds of reports
essays and applications on quality
control method validation six
six sigma risk management and other
laboratory management topics
sten westgard has edited and contributed
to numerous books on quality qc
practices
method validation six sigma qc designing
control six sigma risk analysis
and clia final rules and co-edited
special issues of clinics and laboratory
medicine and biochemical medica
stan is also an adjunct
faculty member of the mayo clinic school
of health sciences
adjunct faculty member of the university
of alexandria egypt
and adjunct visiting
faculty member of university in india
and an honorary visiting professor at a
university in shanghai
stan westgard will now begin his
presentation
welcome
uh this episode or this session is going
to be about
uh six sigma
and about getting your sigma to be not
only strong but stronger
i want to start by making a disclosure
i'm thankful for the opportunity to
connect with you today
abbott is providing the support for not
only my time but for the whole
connection between you and me and all of
the audience
the focus of today is on stronger
harmonization and how it can build
better assays
and simplify your qc and strengthen the
results you deliver to patients
we want to start by understanding what
six sigma is
and why it's not a simple destination
you don't arrive at it and then you're
finished
it's really a pathway
it's a journey
and you must sustain six sigma
not just one day but every day
we'll teach you how to calculate an
analytical six sigma
metric will help you identify
improvements in assay performance
through the lens of six sigma metrics
and then we'll use those six sigma
metrics
to design qc in a better more efficient
way
and the tool that will provide that to
you will be the westgard sigma rules the
latest evolution of westgard rules
now there's also a rather more important
disclosure
uh since
many of you uh
uh have might have tuned into this
session not knowing which west guard
was going to be delivering a lecture
i do want to clarify that for you
you are listening to a westgard that is
stan westgard i'm only
about 25 years into my career so i've
only been doing this for a quarter of a
century
the fellow who's done it for
more than 40 years at the university of
wisconsin
and really more than 50 years of his
entire career is the westgard james o
westgard
the real father of the westgard rules
and myself
together we have put
a resource out to the public at
westgard.com and westgard.org
so when we're not giving presentations
we're trying to make as much material
available to laboratory professionals
around the world our flagship at
westgard.com has more than 70 000
professional members
and there are more than 600 articles
available for free
it's a free membership
and you can
download things you can have
spreadsheets graphing tools
anything on the westgard rules
many many examples of six sigma
we have training
we have social media as well
and in this particular moment
i think no one can deny that quality has
become paramount
even if we look at the tools we've been
using to fight
the global pandemic
just a
little over a month ago
the number of methods on the market
topped more than 1 100.
but of those
only a few hundred are actually allowed
in the united states by the fda
and if we focus on the serology methods
the antibody tests
only 79 are were approved as of may
whereas 264
antibody methods were on a do not
distribute list
that is
three out of four methods
are rejected by the fda
for
use in
fighting this pandemic
a majority of methods on the market are
not good enough
that's a frightening reality
because
if those methods are in laboratories
around the world
well then we might be failing at quality
we might be breaking the trust with our
clinicians and patients
and really it has severe consequences
to the public health
but let's take a step back
not look at 2020 and 2021 but let's go
back
many more decades
some of you may remember these things
pipetting by mouth or the use of flame
photometers
or the smac
the first automated instrument from
technicon
and then there is the use of two sd
control limits
all of these things are
decades old
some of them are half a century old
but probably one of those techniques
seems like it's not old it's something
you're doing right
now but really if you don't pipette by
mouth anymore you also shouldn't be
using two sd control limits
when we look at a modern survey
of qc
practices we find there are three main
pains or bad habits
the use of limits that are too tight
known as anorexic qc
the repeating of controls over and over
known as gambler qc or the use of
ranges or limits that are far wider than
what an individual laboratory should
have and we call that blind man qc
in our surveys
not only in 2017 but even our ongoing
survey this year
we find that every laboratory
i should say every country
in the world has these problems every
type of laboratory has these problems
and all of these bad habits
burn up time and money and cause a lot
of unnecessary frustration
for instance if we look at the use of
two sd practices even though it's really
a half century old tradition not science
a majority of labs are using two sd
limits
and the problem
with two sd limits it's not just that
it's been done
for 50 years it's that the false
rejection rates from two sd limits are
incredibly high
if you're using three controls it's a 14
plus rejection rate
if you're using two controls it's about
one in ten runs are expected to be out
of control even when nothing is wrong
with the method
so that means even when the method is
operating perfectly we're placing an
unnecessary burden on our shoulders
we're saying yeah the method could be
perfect but one out of ten times we need
you to chase down an out of control
event that is essentially a ghost
that might have been a practice that was
marginally acceptable back
50 years ago but in today's modern
laboratory
one out of 10 runs cannot be out of
control that's just too much
too much waste
so we need to change qc and that's one
of the reasons why the west guard rules
came around in 1981
which was 40 years ago
and the westgard rules reduced the false
rejection
from the 1 2s approach
it maximized error detection from just a
few measurements
and it also helped figure out when
something was wrong what might be wrong
whether it could troubleshoot or triage
the kind of out-of-control event into
either a random or systematic error
the benefits from westgard rules were
immediately felt
because instead of
nine percent or fourteen percent false
rejection rates they were lowered to
three percent and one percent
there
the
adoption and implementation of westgard
rules
really
dropped the number of outliers and
dropped the number of troubleshooting
events that labs had to go through and
that's why the uh adoption was so fast
and so global and so quick
but those rules from 40 years ago are
not the rules we recommend today
over the decades we have changed how the
westgard rules
are recommended to people for instance
we no longer recommend using the 1 2s
warning rule
again because
even if you only treat a one-two-s
outlier as a warning that warning goes
off so many times
you may not be
you might grow death to it you might
stop listening and ignoring it
so instead we now recommend a modern set
with no
1 2s warning but instead you go straight
to the rejection rules
and not only do we have those
optimized for two controls but also for
three controls
for situations uh
with some assays particularly in
hematology when you might be running
three levels of control use a two out of
three 2s or a 31s or a 6x
and then even more recently
we've adopted six sigma into the
westgard rules themselves so six sigma
westgard rules you put them together you
have westgard sigma rules
and what you'll notice is
the rules look pretty familiar it's the
bottom of the
graphic that has changed
you now see little dotted lines and
delineations for six sigma five sigma
four sigma and three sigma
and essentially what you need to know is
the sigma of your test
and if you know that you will know how
many westgard rules
you need to use
and what you might be able to see here
is that at six sigma you don't need all
the westgard rules
you just need one rule
it's not a multi-rule approach it's a
single rule approach
and you can see
at the other side three sigma
is when you need all the westgard rules
so this is one way we can reduce the
burden of qc on laboratories
as laboratories
have better and better quality in their
assays they do fewer and fewer westgard
rules
but as
we've introduced the westgard
sigma rules we probably need to cover
the concept of six sigma
six sigma is really a technique that
allows us
to
prevent our use of bad methods so we
won't adopt or bring into our laboratory
a bad quality method then we'll also
not do any of these bad qc habits
six sigma is the goal of the approach
and essentially it means out of a
million reportable results
you have less than four defects
and six sigma has been used many places
are
many different industries
and the achievement of six sigma is
found
to
be associated with the best efficiency
the most satisfied customers the
greatest reliability and the highest
profitability
if it helps to understand what kind of
processes are six sigma
think about airline safety i don't know
if you remember when we all used to go
on to planes or not
maybe we'll be able to do this again
soon
but in the u.s at least there are less
than 3.4 crashes per million departures
so
safety is actually better than six sigma
in the us or it was before the pandemic
two things in the laboratory the number
of samples that get damaged in transport
or the number of samples that aren't
stored properly before analysis
in an
ifcc assessment of pre-analytical
quality
those two
uh processes came in at six sigma
five sigma is considered excellent
it's really
not that many defects it's 233 now per
million reportables
and this is closer to
how often we see a misidentified test
request or how often samples are
misidentified
four sigma
is considered good performance now we're
at six thousand
[Music]
defects per million
and that's closer to
the rate of misplaced checked luggage so
how often does your
checked bag take a different vacation
than you do
about one in 300.
how often
does your specimen come in and not have
the enough sample
volume to actually run all the tests
that have been ordered
how often is your sample humalized
well we know that's a very
chronic problem for many laboratories
and that is about a four sigma process
three sigma is the minimum acceptable
performance now we're at 67 000 defects
per million
and just to again associate it with
something that happens in the laboratory
how often are your microbiology samples
contaminated again that's a chronic
problem
and
it really is the minimum acceptable
quality
in most
laboratories below three sigma is
considered unacceptable now we're in the
hundreds of thousands of defects if we
get below one sigma we're worse than a
coin flip
departure delays for the for the u.s
airlines
which
are around 30 percent or were around 30
that's a below three sigma process and
that
helps on helps us understand why
we are often frustrated with airlines
and hate the way they treat us and yet
we feel extremely safe about getting on
a flight
and
we're very confident that we'll be able
to get off that plane at the end of the
trip
in the laboratory when we want to
measure six sigma performance we need to
know
imprecision and inaccuracy your cv and
your bias
these are gained from your controls and
either through your eqa or proficiency
testing or your peer group
and then you can put those together
along with the total allowable error
which you can look up
many different places where that's
located but
the westgard.com
website has uh
most of those resources available in a
free section
you take the allowable total error
you subtract the absolute value of your
bias and you divide it by the cb
and with that you will now have a sigma
metric
again once you know the sigma metric
then you can come to the westgard sigma
rules
and if it's a five sigma
you look where that dotted line goes and
it's now you need to now you know that
you need three west guard rules the one
three s two two s r four s
and if you look closely at this
particular graph
you will notice that there not only are
the six sigma
delineations but there's also suggested
run sizes just in the last few years
you've been able to adapt the westgrade
sigma rules to now give you qc frequency
the mathematics to determine
your optimal qc frequency now exists and
we've incorporated them into the
westgard sigma rules
another way to look at the sigma
performance is to use what we call a
method decision chart
and this is just a visual way to
understand sigma metrics taking the
imprecision along the x-axis and the
bias on the y-axis
and the diagonal lines
break up the graph into different sigma
zones with six sigma being
closer to the graph's origin that's
what's labeled world class
five sigma is excellent four sigma is
good three sigma is marginal remember
it's the minimum acceptable quality two
sigma is poor and less than two sigma i
hope we can all agree is unacceptable
it's easier think about it as the
targets just like we were looking at
earlier
the center of the bullseye is the six
sigma and the closer you get to it the
fewer defects you have and the more
confident you and your clinician and
your patient can have with the veracity
of the results
but as you have more imprecision
as you have more bias that means more
defects are being generated
more noise is starting to contaminate
all of the results
and near the graph sorry near the upper
right quadrant of this
graph
really you're reaching the point where
you're confusing clinicians more than
helping to confirm a diagnosis
and this graph can be
found in a free download
as well as an online tool
for free at the westgard website
now let's talk about standardization and
harmonization
we always talk about we don't want to be
carrying uh comparing apples to oranges
there's a much more scientific way to
talk about that not just apples and
oranges oranges but really metrology
and
many of you may have seen this
this is the latter or sometimes i call
it the shoots and ladder of metrology
and standardization at the top is the
pure true measurement and then
there's all these different steps that
get taken
as you move
from standard or truth down to
the manufacturing of the method
and the calibration of the method and
then the routine result down at the
bottom
and the more steps you take it's more
the more possible you get further away
from the truth
there's a lot of
terminology associated with this
there's standardization there's
harmonization which is what you do when
you have no standard but you still want
results to be close to each other
there's traceability which is how good
are you at being closer and closer to
that true answer
and then uncertainty which is as you get
further down
if you go down those shoots
you get more and more uncertainty
and obviously you want
as little uncertainty as possible on
that result
it's not possible to avoid all
uncertainty but you want to minimize it
as much as possible
the benefits from having a standardized
or harmonized assay really accrue to the
patients first and foremost
if you have
results that are stable across labs and
platforms and instruments and methods
then the patient can move through a
health system
and not have to worry that
they were tested on one instrument at
this hospital and then another
instrument at another hospital and those
two results are
incomparable therefore we can't
understand what's going on with the
patient without baselining them first
so this will be much better if we could
be standardized and harmonized for the
patients
would also be really good for
laboratories because then it becomes
easier to interchange the methods and
instruments
if you it also means not only is there a
standard
true answer that you're delivering
but you have a standard level of quality
that you can rely on
manufacturers
strangely or i suppose on purpose
they have the least amount to gain from
standardization and harmonization
they do it because it's good for the
patient they do it because it's good for
their labs for the customers
but really the more we do this the more
we commodify the assay
and that will mean it's
uh the pro the quali the quality of the
assay becomes less important because
we've all achieved
the requisite level of quality
so i do view this as a victory
in that science trumps commercial
interests here
the pursuit of standardization and
harmonization is a pure good for
patients
manufacturers if uh you know if you
what they probably would like most of
all is here's a method and no one else
can do it it's only us and therefore
they have a monopoly on the market
but luckily
through our professionalism through our
science
we push all the manufacturers to make
their methods better
and closer to each other
it's good for us in the lab and it's
great for the patients
there is an underlying assumption that
each new wave of standardization and
harmonization will improve the
analytical quality um and
for the most part that is observed and
seen yes as assays get better uh
as assays get closer to a standard they
are getting better in quality
it is however possible
um
and if we look at a lot of chinese
products flooding the market we may
accidentally get standardized
to a bad level of quality
the standardization approach is let's
get better to truth and
better to high quality
now here's where our
method decision charts come into play
and what i'm showing you is uh six
different assays and we're going to see
them
in the next slide as well
these this is current performance
on unlimited at winchester medical
center in the u.s
so this is
the current level of quality
for these assays except urea is not
plotted because urea was very poor in
performance
and in our sigma verification program if
you're below four sigma we don't plot
you
we just uh we won't qualify them for our
program
here are the new sigma strong assays
albumin bcg and bcp
and amylase and cholesterol
and creatinine and total protein and
urea and uric acid
we can see this new wave of assays
almost all of them are at six sigma
and then one is at five and one is at
four
one of the interesting things
not only are these assays being
standardized to better and better truth
but they're also being
given tighter and tighter goals for
quality
so
in the previous set of assays amylase
was only being held to a 30 allowable
total herb
which is the clia standard
but the eureka standard is now being
imposed
which is essentially
having the quality requirement
and it's 15.7 percent now
creatinine goal could have been
35.4 percent by clia at that particular
level where we were measuring
but actually they're imposing a 20
goal
this is from the national
kidney disease education program and the
17 goal which is standard by clia has
been replaced by a 13 goal
this is
pretty unusual to see a manufacturer
not only do they re-standardize the
assay moving it closer to the truth but
then they tighten the goal
they say
we're not going to try and hit the old
target we're going to try and hit a new
and more difficult target
that's really
impressive and uh just to be uh to be
honest i have rarely seen a manufacturer
be this hard on themselves
when developing a new assay so real
credit
to these sigma strong assays for
adopting
[Music]
tighter goals
here's an example of the
the difference
so on the albumin i'm sorry in the
uh the amylase
assay
a 1992 clio goal
has been replaced by a ricoh skull
and you can see there's
it doesn't matter that you've shrunk the
goal you're still in the bullseye it's
still at six sigma quality
for creatinine
the clia goal of 1992 was first used and
then
the tighter goal
which is by the national kidney disease
education program was imposed
so the impact of that
means it's not a world-class assay it's
now a excellent assay
uric acid
that assay went when benchmarked against
the clia original clear goal is six
sigma but
under the tightened
goal which is now really bach which is
the german
[Music]
a german set of allowable total heirs
even when a tighter goal from the
germans are imposed it is still a six
sigma assay
now we're not trying to hit
smaller and smaller goals just for
the ability to say we're hitting these
goals
there is a a payoff to a better assay
and if you were using
westgard rules in the classic
formulation so you have the warning rule
you're running two
controls and in
with the 8x you're looking across four
runs
if you actually benchmark the quality of
your assay
and use westgard signal rules to
redesign how you do qc
well if you happen to achieve six sigma
and as we saw in the previous slides
almost all these assays are at six sigma
then you can reduce the number of rules
you implement by more than 80
and you can reduce the number of runs of
qc by 75
and how about that false rejection
instead of it being
9 or 14 from
2sd now you're
almost going to completely eliminate
the false rejection
i know that sounds
almost fanciful that you could reduce
all of your qc effort by that much but
we have a decade
of experience in the field where it is
being done
so here's winchester medical center at
valley
health this is in virginia and for the
nine year lifetime of their architect
instruments
when they implemented this approach
they found an 85 reduction in their qc
failures
and they found that there was an hour
less a day
that they had to spend working that
instrument
and when you quantify all of those hours
into a savings
the labor savings is more than a hundred
thousand dollars over the lifetime of
the instruments
that's certainly something that makes
the laboratory happy the idea that you
don't have to be standing in front of
the box
all those hours
and repeating controls and
running new controls and recalibrating
and calling technical support all of
those things go away
but also turned out that there was a
hard dollar savings because they ordered
fewer controls
and they consumed fewer
supplies and they burned less reagents
by running fewer because they had fewer
controls to run and over the
lifespan of the instruments nine years
that was a hundred sixty thousand hard
dollar savings
so you put those soft and hard together
that's a quarter of a million dollars
you save over the long run on these
instruments
and you know this is
something you can actually demonstrate
to your administration or your manager
high quality
does actually save you money
and it does not this kind of money
savings does not sacrifice the quality
of the result
so in conclusion
we do see like everything in the
laboratory
there's always constant change and it
will happen with the westgard rules too
and it will happen
with how you run your qc
but those changes are going to be for
the better
the results
you will know just how reliable they are
you can back up a
clinician questions a particular result
you can tell them look this is a six
sigma assay i only expect to be wrong
four times out of a million
and then the tc can get much easier for
you you'll have fewer rules you'll run
fewer controls you may even be able to
run less often
the westgard sigma rules
are a way
to simply look at all of these
savings and benefits you get out of six
sigma
and
again
through
the new wave of assays that are better
standardized and better in performance
that will
increase the benefits
of using six sigma of using western
sigma rules
will reduce
even further the number of
out-of-control events you have
will reduce even further
the amount of supplies and reagents you
need to consume
and reduce even further the amount of
time you have to spend
chasing out of control events
and with that i want to thank you for
your time
thanks for joining this session and i
know we're going to have a question and
answer session x next thank you thank
you again to abbott
for supporting supporting us and
enabling
uh us to be able to connect
to all of you
finally
you'll see that
email address down there sten
westgard.com
part of the mission of westgard is not
just to present the tools but also to
help labs
implement them so
i encourage you to ask questions in the
q a session to follow but if something
occurs to you later as you're digesting
and ruminating
on these lessons
please feel feel
feel free to reach out
and email me
thank you
all right thank you stem for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's go ahead and get started
your first question is then
what is the best way for labs to
determine precision to calculate the
sigma value
must i do multiple days and multiple
lots to get a value
that's a great question thank you very
much michelle
glad to see so many questions coming in
for precision
in our own program of sigma verification
we ask for a hundred data points
and
that could cover
three months on a chemistry if you're
running once a day
if you're running
uh more often
then that that's a
shorter time period
and that that's kind of in line with
the clsi c24 document which is
uh
that
expresses a lot of the best practices
for qc and it recommends getting an
estimate of three to six months
of data to give yourself a cumulative
cv and a cumulative mean so we're
matching that at least on the minimum
side do you have to do multiple uh
reagent lots
well that that could be nice um
and certainly if you're
if you're doing this on the hematology
or other tests where you have very short
reagent lot life
probably that's just going to happen
naturally as you as you try and get so
many
data points but on
other
other instruments i would say with a lot
of chemistries where you have very long
shelf life
even for the reagents that
you may not have to
get multiple reagent lots
if it's a very stable assay
you probably don't need that extra
information
okay
go ahead for the next question
wonderful all right um where is this
approach usable
that is a very broad question so let's
first talk about um
where in the world it could be used and
in our again our sigma verification
program
we have labs all over
um so we have them in asia we have them
in india
um
we have them in europe we have them in
south america we have them in russia we
have them in north america
so sigma metrics
formally are being used almost
everywhere
but maybe
that's on a country or region basis
within a single laboratory
we see
uh sigma metrics being used
most often in the chemistry
immunoassays
is probably the the second most popular
area and then from that point on you
know toxicology endocrinology
and we're starting to do work to try and
move it into the serology testing area
to make adaptations for
semi-quantitative
for semi-quantitative assays now
to step back again the sigma equation
is is agnostic
so if you say i have an allowable total
error i have a bias i have a cv
the sigma equation doesn't say well wait
a minute where are you from
and then start rejecting you oh no
you're from the wrong country or you're
the wrong kind of test
the equation itself if you give it
numbers that make sense that are
realistic
it will give you a sigma metric so the
application of this approach can be
quite broad
all right thank you sen
your next question for sigma metrics
calculation do you recommend to derive
the bias from the difference between the
eqa assigned value and the labs value
if not what would you suggest
that's a great question there
indeed multiple ways to calculate the
bias and probably the most
formally correct way
to calculate the bias is to say
i have
an eqa or proficiency testing program i
measure my values and then i'm compared
against
um peer group values or all group
values or if we're if we're lucky we
have
an accuracy based uh survey and we'll
get compared to
a reference method or a reference
material
the downside of calculating bias that
way is it it takes a long time and we
don't get many data points so typically
in the in the u.s
two to three times a year we're getting
maybe five samples
so we might only get 15 measurements in
a year where we can compare ourselves to
a
a target
value
or group consensus value or a reference
value and then determine our bias
a peer group program on the other hand
but we can get data off that probably
every day
and it will include all of our qc data
points not just a handful or a dozen
um
survey points
so
oftentimes by in pragmatic terms
and
ease of accessibility
using a peer group and comparing your
mean against the peer group mean
is a practical way to determine your
bias a final way to to determine your
bias is to use an acid control
and if the assay control on the package
insert it says this you know for your
instrument
we've tested this and it looks like this
should be your mean
and then you look and you calculate your
own mean what's that difference well
that difference is also a bias
so my own preference and again this is
my bias about bias is to use a peer
group program simply because there's so
much data
and it's so easily available through
most of the peer group programs so you
can you can update your bias estimates
more than once or twice or three times a
year
thank you stud
all right your next question how often
do we need to evaluate an assay to check
whether the sigma metric is maintained
that is a very great question and i
think
um
it's asked very frequently and i i think
people worry that a sigma metric is
something they're going to have to
calculate every day
and then that adds a whole new set of
numbers that they have to manage
the sigma metric in practice in the
laboratories that we have in our
verification program
we encourage them
to do it at least twice a year but we
often find
the labs will do it every month
so at the same time they're doing a
monthly qc review
they're also taking a look at their
sigma metric because essentially the
same data is is used you you have an
updated
cv
maybe you have an updated bias from your
peer group
well that can help you recalculate your
sigma metric
but just because we're looking at that
metric every month or every quarter
that does not mean the sigma metric is
going to change significantly
in some labs uh we've been working with
them for over a decade and their sigma
metric fluctuated a little bit but they
didn't change their rules
for nine years
so they had an assay and it stayed in
the same sigma category
for the whole life span of it of an
instrument
so we don't see a lot of changes in qc
even if we're monitoring that sigma
metric
on a monthly basis
at least
with a lot of the major
instruments and the most robust methods
that sigma metric doesn't change
significantly very often
so
you might check your sigma metric every
month but you're probably going to have
the same set of rules for that entire
year
okay your next question looks like a
three-part question
um
so this user says excellent talk can you
please comment on when qc is commonly
run for instance immediately after daily
maintenance or once a shift
can different concentrations be run at
different times instead of together at
the same time
so uh
it might seem like a three-part question
but it's actually uh an all-of-the-above
answer
that um very often after you've done
your startup routine on the instrument
it's a convenient time to run the qc to
make sure
everything is is working correctly
because of course
wouldn't we all like to know um before
we start running patients if the
instrument is out of control
then
for some labs and sometimes it's
mandated by regulations or sometimes
it's just driven by
the professional ethic
that
yes i can run qc once a day and i will
do something upfront but i might also
want
to space and stagger qc throughout the
day
so that i own i'm looking at more than
just a snapshot of this morning i'm
getting
uh
i'm getting a glimpse of qc in the
afternoon and if we have a third shift
we're getting a glimpse
in the night and some people will indeed
take different levels
and so they're running one level
in the afternoon and they run a
different level in the evening
so
uh all of those things are
fall within your professional judgment
particularly in the us and if you um go
by iso 15189
but the general consensus is you must at
least run qc
twice once a day once a day and usually
it's two controls or more
as i mentioned in the presentation
depending on the sigma metric
you may actually need to run more qc
that is take more measurements and even
run more often the lower your sigma goes
so there's a regulatory floor
under which you're not supposed to go
but then if you know how good or bad
your method is that should also dictate
how often you're going to run your qc
all right thank you
okay we have time for a couple more
questions here let's move on to this one
i understand the use of sigma for
establishing and running qc is there an
application for anticipating or
determining sigma as part of new method
evaluation and if so how might this be
approached
that is a
very good observation and
not only can you use it to determine how
you operate you can use it to determine
whether or not you accept the method
so if you think about method
verification or method evaluation that's
when you just get you're getting a new
test or a new instrument into your lab
of course you would like to make this
sigma metric judgment
to be able to say
uh this box is good let's
get it into routine use or to be able to
say well there's a couple assays on here
that
aren't very good and either the
manufacturer needs to
check and maybe make some improvements
or fix something
uh to improve those assays or this might
be considered a box that we don't accept
maybe it's you know the the lemon box
and there's a we have to get a
replacement instead
so the same data that you use that you
calculate
in your method
evaluation process you run a precision
study you do a comparison of method
study
those help you determine cv and bias so
you get the same ingredients
for a sigma metric that you do from your
routine qc and your proficiency testing
so not only can you use that method
evaluation data to accept or reject
the method you can even project out and
say not only do i know if i have a good
or bad method but if i choose to keep
that method and put it into routine use
i also have an idea of how i'm going to
run qc for that method
okay
now if an assay is determined as a six
sigma assay how many times do controls
need to be run
so the westgard sigma rules when you
have a six sigma assay they give you a
very simple rule of thumb which is
widen your limits out to 3s
3sd
and you're going to run that you
probably run two levels of control if
it's a chemistry control
three levels of control if it's a
hematology control or you know depending
on
the
type of assay you'll have two
measurements or three measurements but
you won't need any other rules
and the information on frequency
tells us when we calculate
the
[Music]
acceptable qc frequency rate for a six
sigma assay it's roughly
about
one qc measurement or i should say you
make the qc measurements
whether it's two or three controls
about every thousand patient samples
so for many labs that just means you
have mathematically justified doing qc
once a day
but the the science
now uh supports what has been up until
now in arbitrary practice
all right thank you sten we will go
ahead and wrap up with this last
question
do you recommend only clia or rilabox
for the total allowable error
that's a great question it's uh
when we talk about harmonization and
standardization unfortunately
the goals that we use around the world
need a standardization and a
harmonization
it's a a crazy thing but the goals being
applied in germany by the really black
rules are different than the goals being
applied in the us and in cap
laboratories by the clia goals sometimes
those differences are quite dramatic
so one of the things we do at westgard
is we try and keep track of all the
different
goals available
across the globe
and we put them in a comparison that you
can look at for free
again it's in our quality requirements
section on westgard.com
and then we ourselves
in our verification program we make a
recommendation
when we choose a goal that we think is
optimal
we don't choose the smallest goal
because we don't like to choose goals if
actually no one on the market can hit it
and there are a set of goals out there
where
yes they may be very scientific
but nothing
on earth is able to achieve that level
of quality
so that goal
might be something that is aspirational
for the next
set of research and design engineers at
our diagnostic providers but we need a
different goal to govern how we run the
tests that we have today
so we make a
an assessment of
the practicality of goals and in our
program we don't try and choose easy
goals
we always try and choose a goal that is
achievable but it is also
um
challenging so we want to make sure that
we don't have a goal that oh any method
can hit this
um it really it's not it's not so much
a test as a rubber stamp no we always
try and assess the performance of
instruments and labs out there to figure
out how can we
challenge them
to achieve
a little bit better quality in the
future
thank you very much sen do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go today
well i just want to thank everybody for
taking the time
your uh
that's the most valuable resource that
you have right now is your attention and
your time
and the fact that you have been willing
to focus on quality speaks highly of
your professional commitment
it's really important as you move
forward to keep that quality focus
in the center of your vision
[Music]
and i i think i i should say i hope that
the tools that we
have provided to you
help you sharpen your focus on quality
and make it easier for you to see
how you can get the best methods in your
laboratory how you can get the best
operation of qc in your laboratory and
deliver the best results to your
patients
thanks again for your time i hope you
have a good rest of your day
thank you again sten westgard for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye